yesterday after the games everybody went
to the soccer match and the Magnus kept
scoring you know he never stops no
matter what he plays actually I think he
scored a couple of goals right and then
also I know that the Christian also did
really great job and the Grandmasters
beat the organizer 7-3 so this was this
final score so you can see now on the
video of Magnus and the other players
actually olivon aronian came Maximus
telegraph was there yes we had so much I
had a lot of fun watching you guys and
it was really nice
yes it was a good assist good assist by
Magnus you're in a good shape and
actually Magnus answered Hiro shared our
story in Instagram and he had answered
that it's always ready to assist you
Christian it was so nice to see him
actually to see this moment yes he's a
very good player of course he's he runs
well I think he controls the ball very
well he's good at sports he generally
enjoys playing this type of things